what's fascinating about this video
wasn't even their response
what fascinated me even more than that
was their straight face when they said
it is there is there a number that
stands out to you as like a decent
salary like something that you would be
like okay he needs to make this much
money if he's not ever making more than
let's say a hundred thousand dollars
then I would be a little bit worried
about our future I would say somewhere
between
uh 400k
forever like
there's no bar yeah somewhere around 80
to 100K in your mid-20s which means they
have no conception how difficult it is
to get to that kind of financial level
no
because even if you look at the numbers
how many people actually make that
amount of money
by that one that said by like 23. 23 or
like mid-20s 23 she said 80 to 100K I
was like who what
right as she said it was such a straight
face like what she thought was normal
then the other girl says 400 to whatever
there's no bar
like it's normal that is how
disconnected they are and now at one
point they're talking about you know so
we can live a life of leisure say enough
to
live a life of leisure in a sense
if you're making that kind of money
generally you're working overtime you're
not taking holidays off you're working
all the time because to get that kind of
money I think people have this idea of
making lots of money and think it's just
incredible flexibility I can travel when
I want I can go where I want I can spend
the money however that's not what it is
you got the money you just don't have
the time
you got Superstars you know they're
making a lot of money and stuff like
that like
you think they always have the time to
to go out
like someone like for example Kevin Hart
that has kids a wife side chicks uh
someone like Kevin Hart to have wife
girlfriends
wife kids and does
four movies a year
four movies a year manages a company
you think you can just take off with his
bonus kids for three months and then
living lavish Mojo gets divorced because
why because the wife says he don't spend
enough time with me
it's like yo it is
there's numbers out there right about
how the fact that vast majority of the
highest earners in the world all right
I'm talking about people who make like
seven figures eight or like vast
majority of them are men okay yeah and
people are like oh wage I believe no
it's because like the kind of mindset
you have to have to generally make a lot
of that money is a little bit psychotic
and men just tend to over represent and
kind of in terms of that kind of
behavior because I know dudes who made
that they're not
they're not the easiest people to be
around they're not the most available
people you want to talk about emotional
openness that's not them so not only are
these kinds of men extremely rare but
when you do encounter them oftentimes
they don't have the best relationship
skills because they spend all their time
making money and working like dogs the
the truth of like dudes who make that
kind of money is that vast majority of
them are over the age of 40. so either
they're already married already had kids
or already in a relationship so like
even the numbers that you see the stats
online are for dudes who are well over
the average dating age so that's why
when I hear this stuff I'm like yo some
of y'all sound crazy
it's not an enjoyable dating experience
that's why when I hear them talk about
Leisure and be able to relax and do
that's not their lifestyle at all so
what is it that people seek out and you
realize it's extreme Comfort they think
that once they get a lot of that money
their needs are going to be taken care
of that's what they're really thinking
is going to happen absolutely but
everything's got to trade-off all that
extra money sounds great in theory we
realize on the relationship side of
things you end up sacrificing a lot so
everything has its trade-off all those
dudes that make that tremendous amount
of money guess what they're far more
desirable than the average man what also
means is like
if you're not trying to share them odds
are Fidelity is probably not in the
carts those are all aspects of it that
are real so when I hear folks talk about
I'm like I don't think you know what
this really entails
because if you did you'd come with an
insurance plan
most people I know that are in their
mid-20s are in school the ones that are
going to make that kind of money yeah so
once I made that kind of money at 23
they are in school
okay
and those were not in school and making
that kind of money I don't know them but
those weren't that at that age made that
kind of money
only work and the other side of the
people that make that kind of money
don't always work Earth cameras and
criminals
but at least they got a pop in Instagram
at least they got to pop in Instagram
you know what I mean so it's like
um listen bootang
that's not realistic at all no but hey
but at some point you're gonna wake up
and you're gonna be uh feeling bad about
yourself because you're gonna be lonely
you're not gonna find what you want
there's no man out there there's no good
man out there there's no good man out
there like man out there are trash they
don't they don't have maybe you're
standing maybe it's your standards that
are trash
maybe your standards are unattainable
maybe but let's put that on man let's
see you know and no no it's just a man
out there they don't make that kind of
money do you
do you make that kind of money
because you attract what you you know
your track which you make that kind of
money what you mean a lot of money on
your track what does that mean what
if you're around that if you're around
that kind of people what kind of people
people that make a whole lot of money
all right you're a girl [ __ ] either
you a thought
or you made that kind of money
it's one or the other I mean you can get
lucky on online dating yes
you can look get lucky I sure uh Corner
Store Bodega uh hit a million on the
ticket yes you can hit the Powerball you
can get lucky yes yes you can get lucky
absolutely you're right chances are
though you're not gonna
so
if it's not around you you're not making
that kind of money then people are not
around you
how I don't know I don't I'm probably
wrong
I'm not dating so hey man listen Maybe
maybe these lazy girl gonna grow up and
then realize what their stuff is
unrealistic right same way a lot of
dudes think that they're gonna make
seven figures probably not okay 99 of
you gonna fail to make that kind of
money some delusional guys out there who
think they're gonna make a lot of
probably not gonna happen okay
so you know if people want to have
unrealistic expectations out of life
that's fine you're entitled to generally
the way that you over achieve in life is
by having unrealistic expectations so
that's also a weird part of things but
fair but fair I will say when your
expectation is predicated on the idea
that not your own hard work or your own
labor okay but you finding someone else
who's gonna do it it's a little bit
weirder it's one thing if you say I'm
gonna be a billionaire I'm like all
right well good luck and work on it no
but it's a different thing you say I
don't need a billionaire we gonna get
married I'm like okay [ __ ] you crazy
reason being is you're not even in
control of that
at least if you were doing the labor I
could respect it you just roll them dies
and hope he looks at you and wants to be
a committed individual that's weird
that's weird that's a fact listen I
think 100K as a combined is very
reasonable and attainable for vast
majority of couples okay okay were they
within your very reasonable and
attainable but this whole thing of just
putting it all on the dude is so wild to
me
especially in the age where women are
getting more and more educated getting
down and settled down much later in life
the idea that you still hold these same
unrealistic expectations it's just wild
we're no longer in the Middle Ages it's
not 1950 anymore y'all got your degrees
y'all got your careers you guys are
you know right getting your bbls tummy
tucks doing all this stuff buying your
accessories buying your body whatever
but you guys still want to hold these
same standards well listen there's not
enough men out there for you and these
men are not checking for you because
they don't really care that much because
they got more flexibility and it's crazy
to me that the dudes with way more
are way more flexible in what they look
for than these ladies
isn't that odd that you come with less
qualifications but have higher
expectations it's funny that the person
that are that have the most to offer the
most to offer the most the one that I
have the most options are the most
flexibles about their options yeah
because what was funny about that video
it wasn't just what they were saying but
the straight faces like what they said
wasn't crazy
400k to whatever there's no limit
there's no bar
but I think they just want to live easy
life on easy mode they want to do that
Instagram life where they're traveling
everywhere they think them their husband
they're gonna be on some [ __ ]
beachfront in Maui but you know what I
mean chill it while he's making duckets
buying her a new purse and she taking
pictures drinking everything out of a
coconut drink I get that y'all want that
but that's not how most rich people live
they're too busy making more money
why do you think they hire escorts
wonder why because when they're
traveling they don't have time to court
people nor is it good for their business
so they just pay
they're like I'm in town for the night
make be there 7 P.M
why do you think that is they don't have
time
they're not around their families that
often so I'm just like if you want to
talk about this that's fine just make
sure you know what that [ __ ] entails
because the rich dudes
it's well put together
look at YouTubers
got the most well put together and those
dudes make a lot of money
all right so go ahead would you want to
say no no that's pretty much it
the lack this is this
then again
then again
you watch Instagram and that's all you
see girls living lavish traveling and
stuff like that they're Sugar Babies
okay okay
okay
yeah okay they just don't tell you but
they sugar babies or
[ __ ]
or what's the alternative well there's
one alternative that makes sense
because sometimes I'll see women with
those pictures and I'm looking at them
like
I know you you ain't got money like that
so what's the alternative to them being
sugar babies or only fans bottles mommy
and daddy
yes what's the third option
and the only one that makes sense you
ready for it
your hairline Airline store yes that's
it that's the one that's the one
obviously go travel a lot I'm like are
you flight attendant because I don't
but then again you're not taking
pictures with these camels for no reason
I'm just saying but then again
being a like
being being a flight attendant in the
first few years you're not gonna make
them duckets you're gonna have the
flights you're gonna have the flights
but you're not gonna make that you know
I thought you're gonna say yeah then
again being a flight attendant in the
first few years you a hoe
they do not treat you the best way those
companies let me tell you that no but
traveling is great but the way they
treat some of them employees is not
amazing so yeah technically hmm uh yeah
that's how it's gonna feel all you
people watching like ah but I got
pictures of me traveling I'm not a whole
or flight calm down I'm not talking
about your little shitty picture in in
[ __ ] Costa Rica okay I'm talking
about the ladies who got new pictures of
them in a different city every single
time I'm like listen you've been to like
10 countries this year no regular nine
to five gives you that much flexibility
so if you're not hoed or only fans then
you're a flight attendant and if you're
not eating those things they'll beat you
lying straight up
I'm just saying I'm just saying do the
math four vacations a year what kind of
job gives you 10 weeks of [ __ ]
vacation time anybody off the bat off
off the bat you've been working in that
[ __ ] for five years they give you two
months 10 weeks Hey listen get the [ __ ]
out of here listen get the [ __ ] out of
here listen man take all your [ __ ] yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah yeah
yeah no just not but these are
observations
and these are just opinions maybe you
agree disagree you let us know
let us know in the comments below and
that's fine